ever wonder what the g7 is well it's an
informal club like a highschool clique
made up of the major developed economies
the United States Canada the United
Kingdom France Germany Italy and Japan
since the mid 1970s they've been
gathering once a year for a photo op and
to discuss economic policies like
exchange rates international trade
development and you know how to run the
world
it became the g8 when Russia joined but
they got the boot over their role in
Crimea Russia said they didn't care
because they're part of this other group
the g20 who are the new kids on the
economic power block the g20 was created
to counter the influence of the g7 it
includes the g7 plus China Brazil India
and other major emerging countries the
g20 represents 85 percent of the global
economy
you